high level again is it compiled there's
an interpretive language so python is
just in time compilation what's what's
Mojo
so Mojo a complicated answer does all
the things so it's interpreted it's Chip
compiled and it's statically compiled
um and so this is for a variety of
reasons
um so uh one of the things that makes
python beautiful is that it's very
Dynamic and because it's Dynamic one of
the things they added is that it has
this powerful meta programming feature
and so if you look at something like
pytorch or tensorflow or or I mean even
a simple simple use case like you'd find
a class that has the plus method right
you can overload the dunder methods like
Dunder add for example and then the plus
method works on your class and so it has
very nice and very expressive Dynamic
meta programming features
in Mojo we want all those features come
in like we don't want to break python we
want it all to work but the problem is
you can't run those super Dynamic
features on an embedded processor or on
a GPU right or if you could you probably
don't want to just because of the
performance and so we entered this
question of saying okay how do you get
the power of this Dynamic meta
programming into a language that has to
be super efficient in specific cases and
so what we did was we said okay we'll
take that interpreter python has an
interpreter in it right take The
Interpreter and allow it to run it
compile time and so now what you get is
you get compile time meta programming
and so this is super interesting and
super powerful because
one of the big advantages you get is you
get python style expressive apis you get
the ability to have overloaded operators
and if you look at what happens inside
of like pytorch for example with
automatic differentiation you can remote
like all these things they're using
these really Dynamic and Powerful
features at runtime but we can take
those features and lift them so they run
a compile time so your because C plus
has meta programming with with templates
but it's really messy it's super messy
it's it's always it was accidentally I
mean different people have different
interpretations my interpretation is
that it was made accidentally powerful
it was not designed to be touring
complete for example but that was
discovered kind of along the way
accidentally
um and so there have been a number of
languages in the space and so they
usually have templates or code
instantiation code copying features of
various sorts
um some more modern languages or some
more newer languages let's say like you
know they're fairly unknown like Zig for
example
um says okay well let's take all of
those types that you can run it all
those things you can do at runtime and
allow them to happen to compile time and
so one of the problems with C plus plus
I mean which is one of one of the
problems with C plus plus there we go is
wrong words
oh that's okay I mean everybody hates me
for a variety of reasons anyways I'm
sure right I've written that's the way
they show love I have written enough C
plus plus code to earn a little bit of
grumpiness with C plus plus but
um but one of the problems with it is
that the meta programming system
templates is just a completely different
Universe from the normal runtime
programming world and so if you do meta
programming and programming it's just
like a different Universe different
syntax different concepts different
stuff going on and so again one of our
goals with Mojo is to make things really
easy to use easy to learn and so there's
a natural stepping stone
and so as you do this you say okay well
I have to do programming at runtime
after you do programming at compile time
why are these different things how hard
is that to pull it up because that
sounds to me is a fan of meta
programming in c plus plus even
how hard is it to pull that off that
sounds really really exciting because
you can do the same style programming at
compile time and at runtime that's
really really exciting yep and so I mean
in terms of the compiler implementation
details it's hard
I I won't be shy about that it's super
hard it requires I mean what Mojo has
underneath the covers is a completely
new approach to the design of the
compiler itself and so this Builds on
these Technologies like mlar that you
mentioned but it also includes other
like caching and other interpreters and
jit compilers and other stuff like that
you have like an interpreter inside
within the compiler yes
and so it really takes the standard
model of programming languages and kind
of twisted and unifies it with the
runtime model right which I think is
really cool and to me the value of that
is that again many of these languages
have meta programming features like they
grow macros or something right lisp
right yes I know your roots right
um you know and this is a powerful thing
right and so you know if you go back to
list one of the most powerful things
about about it is that it said that the
meta programming and the programming are
the same right and so that made it way
simpler way more consistent way easier
to understand reason about and it made
it more composable so if you build a
library you can use it both at runtime
and compile time which is pretty cool
yeah and then for machine learning I
think meta programming
I think we could generally say is
extremely useful
and so you get features I mean I'll jump
around but there's the feature of Auto
tuning and adaptive compilation just
blows my mind yeah well so okay so let's
come back to that all right so so what
what is what is what is machine learning
like or what is a machine learning model
like you take a pie torch model off the
internet right
um it's really interesting to me because
what a pipe what pi torch and what
tensorflow and all these Frameworks are
kind of pushing compute into as they're
pushing into like this abstract
specification of a compute problem which
then gets mapped in a whole bunch of
different ways right and so this is why
it became a meta programming problem is
that you want to be able to say cool I
have I have this neural net now run it
with batch size a thousand right do do a
do a mapping across batch or okay I want
to take this problem now run it across a
thousand CPUs or gpus right and so like
this this problem of like just describe
the compute and then map it and do
things and transform it or like actually
it's very profound and that's one of the
things that makes machine Learning
Systems really special